you all remember the famous meme
you all know it was a scam we got to
talk bitconnect first sec is going after
them for an alleged two billion dollar
fraud against customers thousands of
victims swindled out of more than two
billion dollars you may even know people
close to you who lost money to it but
how did the scam work what was
bitconnect what did it promise how did
they pull off the biggest crypto ponzi
scheme to ever be criminally charged
where are they now and most importantly
how can you pull this off yourself
theoretically
[Music]
so if i if i if i sell a stock at ten
thousand dollars my commission is five
thousand bucks
[Music]
after being released in 2016 big connect
promised everyone that they held the key
to financial freedom here's how the big
connect platform was supposed to work
bitconnect is here to help you with the
cryptocurrency revolution our open
source system is designed to make the
process of trading staking mining and
investing bitcoin much easier bitconnect
said that their platform would allow
users to lend out a cryptocurrency
called big connect coins and receive
interest payments in return they said
the supply of bitconnects was limited to
only 28 million coins so as the man
would go up for the coin the price was
skyrockets and the people holding the
original big connects would make a ton
of money sounds confusing that's because
big connect wanted people to just barely
understand what they were putting their
money into they wanted to attract people
who didn't know that much about
cryptocurrency so if you're feeling
confused you would have been big next
ideal investor even though the coin was
called big connects everything was
handled in bitcoin the only way for
users to get bitconnect coins was by
trading in bitcoin you could not buy bit
connect with cash or any other crypto
just bitcoin basically you send big
connect your bitcoin and they will send
big connect coins back you traded a real
cryptocurrency that could be converted
to cash for a coin that turned out to be
a ponzi scheme so why would someone want
a big connects the thing about having a
big connect coin is that they generated
crazy amounts of interest extremely fast
we're talking up to a forty percent
return every month guaranteed by the
company that means if you put five
thousand dollars into bitconnect you
could end up with nearly three hundred
thousand dollars just 12 months later
they connect use a four tier system
depending on the user's initial
investments the more money you put in
the more interest you got out every
investor was promised at least a one
percent return on investment every
single day that means that if you put in
1 000 into big connects you could
potentially net over 50 million dollars
in just three years
looking back we can now see how stupid
these promises were but back then when
crypto was still newer and less
understood it was reasonable for average
mom and pops who didn't know anything
about crypto to fall for it it's still
very reasonable for people to fall for
these schemes today but how was all this
possible how could bitconnect yield such
incredible returns well with their super
fancy trading bot of course all the
massive interest payouts were determined
by bitconnect's groundbreaking trading
bot and volatility software the bot knew
the precise moments to trade
cryptocurrency that would turn a small
big connect investment into a fortune it
was this futuristic technology that led
bitconnect generate returns of up to one
percent every single day and there was
another way to make money with big
connects the referral system you see
bitconnect wanted to make sure everyone
knew about them and what better sales
people to use than the people you
already made rich enter the army of
multi-level affiliates
yes bitconnect successfully combined the
best of both worlds ponzi schemes and
pyramid schemes soon a slew of youtubers
influencers and other marketers were
jumping on the bandwagon to promote the
almighty big connect
hello everyone i'm dee and this is
charlie
and as you can tell by our huge mansion
we're insanely loaded they told their
followers that they were straight up
missing out on money if they weren't
investing in big nets urging them to put
every penny they had into the coin
they would show everyone the huge
profits in their online wallets
seemingly providing proof that
bitconnect was the real deal a foolproof
investment but what they were telling
the public was that these profits were
actually coming from all the affiliate
marketing they were doing and in reality
when you peeked behind the curtain there
was no high-tech trading bot or
investment strategy at all they were
simply paying out old investors with the
money from new investors also known as a
classic ponzi scheme and it was about to
come crashing down
one of the most telltale signs of a
sketchy crypto project is when they
don't actually have a working product
they'll sell a coin probably based on
ethereum so it would never be able to
work anyways because they can't scale
promising they're going to build some
revolutionary web 3 products and that
all you have to do is buy the coin and
invest this is a great way to raise a
bunch of money to build something never
build it and then walk away with all the
money but one crypto server that
actually has a live working products
that you can sign up for and use right
now is tune.fm tunefm is the web3 of
spotify that's actually live and working
meaning that you can click the link
below sign up and start listening to
music right now just like you would for
spotify it already has artists like
beyonce on there and basically when the
music gets played the artist gets paid
immediately for every second of
streaming and it's much more than what
an artist can earn on spotify like
upwards of 10x more
the reason this is possible is because
it's run on their native jam token which
is based on something called hedera
hashgraph and not something like
ethereum that is inherently built to
fail because they can't scale with the
slow transaction times and fees an
enterprise level distributed ledger
technology owned by google ibm boeing
and much more this tech is already
working for these giant companies and it
actually allows for fast and cheap
microtransactions unlike fia or bitcoin
or any other coin project you see out
there that's based on an ethereum erc
protocol this allows artists to get paid
right away and it even allows for you
the listener to get paid just by
listening to music on tune fm
that means if you help discover new
music or you help curate music on tune
fm you get paid if this sounds at all
interesting to you tune fm is giving you
guys 100 jam coins for free to give it a
listen right now when you go to tune.fm
with the link below and sign up you have
nothing to lose by giving it a try and
you'll also be helping improve the music
industry so go to tune.fm with the link
below to claim your free 100 jam coins
right now thanks to tune fm for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
how much do you want me to put in 250
on top of the 300 million i already have
with you yes
while the big connect scheme looked a
little different it still demonstrated
all the red flags of a traditional ponzi
scheme where they show insane returns
and then pay off old investors with new
investors money before bitconnect went
down people were already suspicious
about the company for a few reasons
first bitconnect had no white papers to
show their research white papers are
normally used to educate customers about
a company's approach to earn their
confidence this would be especially
important for a company as claiming to
use revolutionary technology like a
trading robot secondly bitconnect
claimed impossibly high payouts and had
a multi-level marketing system for
promoters finally the nail in the coffin
was that big connect was run anonymously
if there's an investment company that
won't even show their face you should
probably run in the other direction oh i
get it now it's a scam
but one of the things that really
started making people suspicious was
carlos matos
[Music]
[Applause]
after receiving a lot of backlash for
their scammy ways bitconnect decided
that their best move was to distract the
public so in october 2017 bitconnect
held his first and only ceremony in
thailand and they invited a man named
carlos matos to be a speaker for the
events a lot of people thought that he
was the leader of big connects but
actually carlos matos was just a regular
investor from new york city he was
basically just like everyone else who
had gotten involved with big connects
and at the time he was making a lot of
money from it so he was thrilled to
promote it to other people when
bitconnect had their ceremony he was the
perfect person to promote them because
the public could relate to him they
would trust him or at least that's what
bitconnect thought would happen
when carlos mattos got on the stage he
ended up giving the performance of a
lifetime
carlos's enthusiastic promotion ended up
becoming a legendary meme and i got a
lot of people talking
so big connect by the way it's honestly
i'm just explaining what it is it's such
a sad scam so they open this platform
called bitconnect and they make this
claim that no matter how much money you
give them they'll make a one percent
return on your investment every day so
they got people to give them a hundred
thousand dollars and they're like we're
gonna give you one percent a thousand
dollars every day on that investment
forget about the word as we know it it's
different it's all chased
in carlos's mine there'll never be any
poor person ever again because you just
give your money to big connect and
everyone gets one percent
[Music]
connect
you see colors proved what many people
were already thinking about big connects
that it was just all smoke and mirrors
big connect was making all these
promises but in reality there wasn't
much more to what they were doing
besides screaming big connect from the
mountaintops they thought carlos
matthews would restore people's faith in
big connects but it actually just made
people even more suspicious
carlos matos was the first domino to
fall that would quickly take down the
whole big connect operation she doesn't
believe in me
i'm telling him
this is real no no no that's a scam
[Music]
there were no returns it was a ponzi
scheme
[Music]
has reportedly vanished even though many
people were skeptical about big connects
the company was still thriving around
this time the big connect coin bcc was
one of the top 20 largest
cryptocurrencies by market share the
value of bcc had risen from 17 cents to
463 dollars
but ponzi schemes aren't made to last
forever less than a month after carlos
matos's meme disaster the uk government
told big bitconnect that they had two
months to prove its legitimacy or else
it would be shut down then on january
2018 texas and north carolina both
issued cease and desist letters to big
connect saying the company has failed to
be transparent about user earnings and
made misleading statements they also
noted that bitconnect was not registered
to sell securities in their states north
carolina also stated that the promoters
of big connects were breaking the law
too all in now the states were claiming
that bitconnect was a complete fraud
bitconnect was left with no other choice
the company couldn't prove its
legitimacy because it wasn't legit at
all so on january 17 2018 bitconnect
officially shut down its operations and
immediately after shutting down the
price of vcc crashed by 92 percent
thousands of bitconnect users lost
everything
they screwed us they ripped us off
it's been a few sad days man
i lost all my savings man
thirty thousand dollars
in big connect
is it correct to say that that was
almost everything that you had that was
everything we had
not almost it was
everything we had on reddit people
shared their stories of putting all
their life savings into big connects one
reddit thread even had the suicide
hotline number in the title saying money
isn't everything your life still matters
after all of this
so what did bitconnect have to say about
the shutdown they essentially told
everyone sorry it didn't work out and
never admitted to any goats
[Music]
the youtubers that promote a big connect
are still active on youtube many of them
have a similar story about what happened
to the prophets from big connects saying
that they were hacked and all their
earnings were stolen one of them still
provides advice about crypto most
recently in 2021 the sec filed an action
against five promoters another recent
development happened in 2021 56 million
in crypto fraud proceeds were seized
from one of bitconnect's top promoters
glenn acaro the us department of justice
stated that these funds will be used to
pay back bitconnect's
acarl pled guilty and is facing 20 years
in prison
and as for carlos mattos the face of big
connects after the truth about
bitconnect was revealed carlos
disappeared from the public for a while
but in 2019 he released a video on his
own youtube channel in this video he
explained how he also lost a lot of
money in big connects just like every
other investor
and that he was actually a victim to
several other similar scams in the past
carlos has lost upwards of 160 thousand
dollars in scams over his lifetime but
he also said that he's still determined
to be successful online and offline
today he posts semi-regularly on his
very strange youtube channel partner
with carlos matos even though bitconnect
was run anonymously it was eventually
discovered that two of the main founders
were divish darjee and sadish kambani
darshi was arrested at the new delhi
airport in august of 2018 and a year
later he was arrested again in
connection with a very similar crypto
scam called regal coin so clearly he
found his niche as for saddish he was
very recently indicted in san diego on
february 25th 2022 satish was charged
with orchestrating an international
ponzi scheme as the founder of big
connects so what's the lesson from all
of this is that if you're gonna make a
ponzi scheme it's best to latch on to
whatever the new trend is in the finance
world that has a lot of hype and that a
lot of people don't understand yet in
this case it was crypto
[Music]
you